hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
going over the chess game of the century
and it was played between Donald Byrne
and Bobby Fischer now most of you are
probably familiar with Bobby Fischer one
of the greatest chess minds of all time
you may not have heard about Donald
Byrne you may have seen this game before
Donnell Byrne is an international master
a very strong international master at
that it's a lot of you may see this and
say you know Bobby Fischer should win
this game easily but you have to keep in
mind that this game was actually played
when Bobby Fischer was 13 years old so
as we kind of go over the moves and
analyzing it and come up with some of
the thoughts behind some of Bobby
Fischer's move it's going to be just
mind-blowing to think that a 13 year old
can come up with some of the stuff that
Bobby Fischer was coming up with in this
game as we go along you'll see some of
the great ideas but at the same time
this this game has not only one of the
best moves in chess history but also one
of the greatest sacrifices in chess
history so I if you haven't already seen
this game it's going to be a real treat
if you have I still think it'll be you
know really great for you to go back and
look at some of the great moves and
analyze them and govern the commentary
that we're going to be discussing today
burn playing the white pieces started
with Knight to f3 simple development
move trying to control the center and
Bobby Fischer responded with Knight to
f6 again just marrying the move here
from here burn played pawn to c4 trying
to gain a little bit control of the
center and Bobby Fischer responded with
pawn to g6 getting ready to fianchetto
his bishop to this g7 square Bobby
Fischer elected to play a hyper modern
defense trying to control the center
with his minor pieces and not really
getting his pawns involved in the center
control of the game until later on Bern
decided to bring his Knight to c3 simple
development move game the same time
controlling the center of the board and
Bobby Fischer continued with Bishop to
g7 burn from here played pawn to d4
again trying to control the center in
Bobby Fischer Castle Don the King set
now the next move was kind of surprising
not because it was a bad move but just
because at this time in chess was very
common for white to play pawn to e4 this
is the Kings Indian defense
buttburn really gave a lot of respect to
Bobby Fischer even though he was 13
years old it was well known that he
really understood a lot of the book
lines and really understood the theory
behind them Bobby Fischer spent a lot of
time studying the game of chess and so
burn instead of opting to play a defense
the Kings Indian defense the he knew
Bobby Fischer was really you know well
in depth at that he decided instead to
go with the line that made sense as far
as opening principle with Bishop to f4
but he thought that maybe Bobby Fischer
wasn't really you know as studied up on
this and then he thought that you know
being a stronger player by title
international master that this would
allow him to you know play a little bit
out of Fischer's strong suit and have a
better game here from here Bobby Fischer
played pawn to d5 this is the Grunfeld
offense and from here why decided to
bring his Queen to b3 and this is the
Russian system so if you want to read up
a little bit on that but really getting
his key his Queen involved really trying
to put a lot of pressure on not only
this d5 pawn here but into the center in
general he's trying to really gain
Center control with this move here Bobby
Fischer as far as you know his move
options he doesn't have a lot of good
moves pawn to c4 is definitely the best
move it does give up the center for
right now but it does take away a tempo
from the White Queen here because the
White Queen is going to have to
recapture and lose a move here so after
the White Queen recaptures then Bobby
Fischer brings his pawn to c6 c6 and
this is kind of a a waiting move that's
trying to not allow white to move up the
board anymore and keep in mind anytime
you see a player especially in the
Grunfeld defense if they're going to
bring their pawn to c6 here more times
than not they're going to sometime soon
bring their knight - to d7 here so
that's kind of what Bobby Fischer's
thinking in the back of his head
from here burn continue to put all the
pieces in place where he wants to he's
bringing his pawn now to e for this does
a few things one it allows his
LightSquared bishop to get out of the
action get developed so he can castle on
the kingside for further king safety at
the same time it's a really good square
Bobby Fischer was really allowing white
to just completely dominate the center
of the board right now and so burn just
you know taking what's given to him he
has the center of the board so he's just
taking that from here as we talked about
before Bobby Fischer had planned on
bringing his Knight to d7 very common
move as far as development he later on
is going to get this Knight you know
kicked off to a different square but for
now this is a completely fine square and
from here burn decides to bring his rook
to d1 you always want to put your rooks
behind pawns as they push up the board
and so this is a logical move to bring
his rook to d1 now keep in mind that his
queen was here before so this night here
on f3 at some point could be pinned down
with the bishop on g4 once this Queen
went away from d1 the pin could no
longer be there but now that the rook is
here on d1 we may see a pin later on
down the road with a Bishop to g4 here
now from here Bobby Fischer decided to
bring his knight to b6 again getting a
tempo this Queens going to have to move
here obviously he's being attacked and
so yes Bobby Fischer is moving his minor
piece twice you never want to move one
of your pieces twice unless you have a
good reason for it and one of those
reasons is to gain a tempo so Bobby
Fischer although he moved this twice is
not going to lose a move since the Queen
has to move and from here Byrne decided
to bring his Queen to c5 now this is a
pretty aggressive move a lot of analysts
that look at this say that would have
been a little safer just to bring the
Queen back to b3 again White has
complete control the center right here
he has a slight advantage and it would
be completely okay to bring this Queen
back to b3 but burn decided to play a
little bit aggressive here and decided
to bring his queen to c5 there's no real
strong attack right now but he just
doesn't want to play passive right now
against Bobby Fischer from here Bobby
Fischer like all great chess players
continued his development by bringing
his
minor piece into the game he brought his
Bishop to g4 now this is the very
aggressive movement as we talked about
before he's pinning this knight down to
the rook here on d1 that was brought
over from a1 and you know we can go
through the entire game and talk about
you know what you know great moves were
made what bad moves were made but I
think one of the worst moves in the game
was the next move by burn and burn
played Bishop to g5 now the problem with
this is white really needs to one finish
his development he needs to get his
light square bishop into the game you
know bringing his Bishop to e2 that only
destroys the pin with his knight on f3
but at the same time it allows his King
to castle on the King side you know have
King safety and at the same time White
has a really good setup what this move
to g5 does is one it wastes the tempo
he's already moved his Bishop to f4 and
again as we talked about you don't want
to move your minor pieces twice unless
you have a good reason in my mind
there's not a good reason to bring your
Bishop to g5 only except to say you're
pinning down my knight I want to try to
pin down your knight if you ever move
your EEP on I'm pinning down your knife
to your queen but it just doesn't do as
much as it should and at the same time
Bobby Fischer has his King Castle he has
complete safety and all his minor pieces
are developed white over here has a good
game if he would just continued his
development the game would have gone
completely different but you know that's
what chess is and this mistake was made
Bishop to g5 and now from here black had
one of the greatest moves the people
said you know chess has ever seen so if
you haven't seen this game if you want
to go ahead and pause see if you can
come up with you know Bobby Fischer's
next move I'm going to highly doubt that
you do but hey if you're some sort of
chess genius and you come up with this
move that'd be fantastic but the move is
Knight to a4 now this move was only made
by Bobby Fischer because Byrne played
his Bishop to g5 the bird wanted
continued his development with Bishop to
e2 and then castle on the Kings side
this moved the night to a
or would not have been as great and the
planet Bobby Fischer had would not have
been able to evolve like it did but in
this case Bobby Fischer knew two things
he knew that the king was not safe and
at the same time he knew that this pawn
on e4 was very very weak if he could
take this pawn out then he could really
have a strong attack on the kingside
because the King right now is not safe
so what he noticed is the defender of
this pawn on e4 is this night here on c3
so he is coming down here and it looks
like he is sacrificing his knight on a4
so that he can gobble up this pawn on e4
now keep in mind here white is not able
to right away take this Knight on a4 and
Bobby Fischer had to do a lot of
calculation and burn and you know his
own right had to do a lot of calculation
because he actually decided to decline
this Knight here on a 4 because he saw
there was really no good move for him in
the continuation if he takes on a4
obviously Bobby Fischer's going to bring
his knight and take on e4 and really
there's three continuations that white
could have here one of them being if he
brings his Queen to e7 and then the
Queen comes down to a5 from Bobby
Fischer attacking the King the pawn
could come to b4 after this Knights
taken and this Knights taken then the
rook could come to e7 if the bishop
comes to e7 to block then after this
trade off right here then the bishop can
could come back to f4 and this excuse me
to f8 and this is going to be very good
obviously white cannot hold on to all
this material and at the same time look
at this pawn structure for white it's
just not very good and as you can see
for Bobby Fischer he has great pawn
structure and everything's pretty much
coordinating together and at the same
time you know the King from white is
still anyone and it's still unprotected
so that's not going to be a good
variation at the same time if we go back
instead of taking with the Queen if we
burn decided to take with his Bishop on
e7 then after you know Bobby Fischer
takes the Queen and Byrne takes the
Queen
the night on a four is going to be
gobbled up and then the bishop is going
to come back to g5 and then after the
trade-off here as you can see right here
the material is the same Bobby Fischer
could continue and take this pawn on b2
but as you can see as far as material
wise Bobby Fischer's completely fine
he's up a pawn and material and at the
same time the pawn structure is
completely obliterated from four burn
and Bobby Fischer still has his pawn
structure intact so those are two and
the last one that people have analyzed
is if he brings his Knight to e4 then
the Queen could come down to c1 but if
his Queen comes down to c1 then
obviously Bobby Fischer come in to a5
now the rook could come over excuse me
the knight could come to c3
and after the bishop comes to f3 in the
exchange happens on f3 then the knight
could come kick back over and capture on
g5 as you can see right here Black is
equalized as far as the material but the
same time we still have this problem
with the the pawn structure very weak
for white and at the same time he still
is not castled and his King is still out
in the open so in this situation Byrne
actually decided to decline the knight
on a for even though it looks like Bobby
Fischer's just giving it up Boren looked
at the variations in stall you know even
though he's giving this up down the road
this is not going to be good for me so
you know when you see that Byrne plays
you know Queen to a3 that's kind of why
if you look at and you say you know why
didn't why didn't you just take on a
floor well that's why he didn't pick on
a4 so Bobby Fischer continued with his
plan he captured the night here on c3
again trying to remove this defender of
the e4 pawn now keep in mind Byrne has
two options he can capture with his pawn
and he can capture with this Queen but
he knows that really Bobby Fischer wants
to come in and take this pawn on e4 and
once he does this then this pawn on e7
is going to be hanging so right now I
doesn't want to take with this Queen
because he wants to attackers his Queen
on a3 and his Bishop on g5 to both be
attacking this pawn here on e7 so just
keep in mind that Bern does take with
this pawn you know from b2 but that's
why if you're wondering why didn't he
take with this Queen
that's exactly why but from here Bobby
Fischer continued with his plan
taking with his knights on from f6 to e4
and again as we talked about before it
was not a free pawn because now Bern was
able to bring his Bishop to e7 from here
Bobby Fischer with his queen being
attacked he brought his Queen to b6
starting to really form a strong attack
against the white king here and as you
can see white in this decision decided
that he really needs to get you know
safety for his King where he's going to
be in a lot of trouble so what he did he
should have done a long time ago he
developed his LightSquared Bishop and he
brought it to to c4 here now keep in
mind he probably should have developed
this a long time ago but it is good that
he decided that he wanted to now get
some safety for his King since Bobby
Fischer's starting to really put a lot
of pressure on the white king for white
Bobby Fischer now decided to bring his
Knight to c3 and capture now keep in
mind that the queen is not going to be
able to recapture here on c3 because now
the route could come over to e8 and is
pinning this bishop down to the King on
e1 so if you're like why don't he just
recapture that's exactly why in this
situation Bobby Fischer would have won
material so instead Byrne brought his
Bishop back to c5 now if you haven't
seen this game go ahead and take a
minute and think about what blacks
should do as far as his plan going
forward in this game from here Bobby
Fischer played rook to e8 again kind of
an in-between move putting the check on
the king the King decided to move to f1
now keep in mind he really couldn't come
to d2 cuz from here the knight could
come back to e4 check the king once the
King moves back to c1 then the bishop
could come to h6 again putting a lot of
pressure
the King now moves to c2 then Knights
going to come back here and take this
Bishop on c5 really just losing a bishop
here are losing material so that's not
going to work so instead after the rook
comes to e8 Byrne decided to play King
to f1 which seems logical enough again
he's still putting pressure on this
Queen on b6 he knows that Bobby
Fischer's probably going to play his
queen somewhere so he's just kind of
waiting here but Bobby Fischer had other
things in plan and he played what a lot
of people perceived to be the greatest
sacrifice in chess history and he
brought his Bishop to e6 now if you came
up with this move I don't believe you
because I looked at this game a long
time and you may be a better chess
player than I am but there's no way that
I'm playing e6 in this chess game but
Bobby Fischer is better at chess than I
am and he did play it even at 13 he was
better than I will ever be so he played
Bishop to e6 and Byrne decided to go
ahead and take the Queen again if you
have a queen you know it's pretty hard
not to take so he went ahead and took
the Queen and then Bobby Fischer went
ahead and played Bishop to c4 and then
just started a windmill tactic and just
started gobbling up all of burns pieces
so from here the king has to come back
to d1 it's kind of forced and so the
knight comes to e2 again this is the
windmill effect the King's going to have
to come back to f1 he gobbles up this
pawn here on the for the King goes back
he brings the knight back King comes
back to f1 he now brings his Knight to
c3 attacking this rook here on d1 the
King has to go back again he continues
to be put in check by this Bishop here
on c4 and he can't come back to the
e-file because this rook is so nicely
placed from on e8 now from here is a
great move you plays pawn takes to b6
and what this does is one it takes
another minor piece but at the same time
it's gaining another tempo because it is
now not only attacking
capturing this piece on v6 but he's
attacking the Queen on a three from here
burn played Queen to b4 again not a lot
of options that he has here and Bobby
Fischer brought his rook down to a four
down you can start to see all the Bobby
Fischer's pieces are really starting to
you know work together this Bishop here
on g7 has this long diagonal covered
holding down you know protection on this
night the Knights protecting the rook
the rook is protecting the bishop so all
those pieces are kind of working
together whereas you can see for white
his Kings over here on g1 is rook on H
ones not doing anything and none of his
pieces are really connected or doing
things so you can really see even though
Bobby Fischer gave up a queen all of his
pieces are working really well together
now after he starts to attack the Queen
the Queen comes to b6
trying to gobble up some material but at
the same time it's still kind of lost
right here Bobby Fischer now decides to
come in and take this rook on d1 and now
burn the side of the he really needs to
get his king out of the way his King
really can't move and so you know a lot
of threats that Bobby Fischer has he can
come down and checkmate you know once he
starts to take some pieces off the board
so he knows that he needs to really
start to try to counter-attack and
really get somewhere for his King to go
here so he plays pawn to h3 and from
here Bobby Fischer decides to go ahead
and take this pawn on a 2 doesn't really
want to have to worry about any pawns on
the Queen side so now he can pretty much
focus all his attention on the Kingston
burn decided to continue and get his
King to some safety brings his King to
h2 here and Bobby Fischer continues to
gobble up more and more material
bringing his knight to f2 and from here
Byrne decided he really needed to do
something with this rook on h1 it hasn't
done anything all game and so he decided
to bring it to be one and trade off
these rooks here because he knows that
this rook on the e8 has been a pain
putting a lot of pressure at the same
time it's kind of a way that he can free
up an attack with his Queen on the black
King here from Bobby Fischer on g8 so
after the the rook comes down to e one
burn now plays his Queen to d8 now Bobby
Fischer has two ideas he could either
one bring his rook to e8 or he could
instead block with his Bishop on f8 and
I think Bobby Fischer chose the better
of the two moves and he played Bishop to
f8 he knows he's going to lose his his
rook either way but by doing his Bishop
here on f8 once Bern plays Knight takes
on e 1 as you can see his knight is
really far away from the action and that
was a super smart move from Bobby
Fischer because he knows if you're going
to trade you might as well have your
opponent you know have his minor pieces
as far as away from the action as
possible there's no real way for this
night here on e1 and this Queen here on
d8 to really you know attack together
unless it's three four five moves down
the road where Bobby Fischer can easily
get all his moves all his pieces
developed exactly how he wants to and
kind of work together very seamlessly
and that's exactly what Bobby Fischer
starts to do he first brings his bishop
to d5 centralizing his Bishop obviously
Bishop's work well in the center where
they can kind of attack the entire board
at the same time he's really starting to
get all his pieces so that they can all
kind of work together so that's his
first movement from here Bern decided to
bring his knight back to f3 again he
wants his Knight can't do anything on e1
so he wants to try to get it back into
the game Bobby Fischer now plays his
Knight to f4 again pretty much all of
those pieces are now protected except
one and that takes place in the next
move and the Queen now comes to b8 and
Bobby Fischer plays pawn to b5 and as
you can see here if you look at all the
pieces this rook here on a two is
protected by the bishop the bishop is
protected by the pawn all of the pieces
are really working you know well
together and there's not a lot that Bern
has here as far as counter planning what
does he really do here you're just kind
of waiting to see what Bobby Fischer is
really going to do because you can't do
much with just one Queen dancing all
over the board Bern decided to play h4
trying to get some sort of counter play
on the Kings side Bobby Fischer said
all my pieces are completely developed
how I want them to I'm going to play h5
it's kind of a waiting move and just to
let you know I'm not going to allow you
to do anything else on the kingside so
burn really doesn't have any moves with
his Queen so he decides to get his
knight involved into the game bringing
his knight to a central square e 5
trying to put some sort of pressure and
now Bobby Fischer decides that he no
longer wants to have his King pin down
she brings his King to g7 at the same
time allowing his Bishop free since his
bishops no longer pin his Bishop if he
wants to later on can come down to d6
have a brilliant pin on this knife can't
do anything obviously he can't take with
his Bishop from b8 because the knight
here from efore would be protecting the
square on d6 so burn saw this and he's
going to have to retreat his King he
cannot lose any more material and he
definitely does not want to have his
only minor piece left pinned down to the
king so he decides to bring his King
down to g1 and now Bobby Fischer plays
Bishop to c5 checking the King here and
that was just really a mating pattern
there's really not a lot that you know
Byrne could do here he does bring his
king to f1 Bobby Fischer now brings his
knight to g3 and again he's just pretty
much going to March burn all the way
down the firing line and then have a
nice little checkmate at the end here so
burn obviously can't come to the second
rank because the rook obviously a rook
on the second rank is always dangerous
and kind of shows one reason why here
and he can't retreat back to g1
obviously because the bishop here on c5
so he has to continue down the board on
e 1 and now Bobby Fischer played Bishop
to b4 and again he has to continue to
march down the it's a forced move he has
no other options and Bobby Fischer now
plays Bishop to b3 forced move to c1 now
he brings his knight back into action
he's now forced again to come to b1 and
now after his knight comes to c3 then
it's going to be checkmate him one after
the nut King comes back to c1
then the rook comes to see to in his
checkmate so a brilliant game by Bobby
Fischer he really showed even
sacrificing his queen he knew that he
could really use all of his minor pieces
you know cohesively and dominate the
game once all his pieces are working
together and white even though he had
the Queen was kind of scattered none of
his pieces were working together that
Bobby Fischer knew that that was the
correct move so fantastic fantastic
sacrifice from Bobby Fischer fantastic
game played by a thirteen-year-old I
don't even know how you play chess at 13
like that but hope you guys enjoyed this
game it is the game of the century
because it was so fantastic if you
haven't checked out the website make
sure you do that WWH s website com and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching